i do get stressed sometimes especially
when the airport looks like this
it's actually pretty packed right now if
we could just get there our flight on
american was delayed because of crew so
we're going to miss our connection
americans are sounding off on the insane
delays and cancellations rocking
airports everywhere as we head into the
july 4th
weekend so far today more than 440
flights have been canceled more than 4
500 have been delayed airlines
struggling thanks to a perfect storm of
problems bad weather staff shortages
pilots threatening to strike and soaring
fuel costs but if you're stressed out
have no fear transportation secretary
pete budajest
he's on the case
is the july 4th holiday a recipe for
disaster given the issues with the
system right now there are going to be
challenges but we're watching it closely
and we're talking to the airlines every
day about their responsibility to make
sure that they can accommodate any
issues that weather or other curve balls
might throw with them a lot of people
including me
are expecting to get to loved ones over
this holiday weekend and we need a
system that is resilient enough to get
them there plus good customer service
when an issue does come up
greg when this administration uses the
word challenge you know it means
hellfire
yeah i i you know um i just love i can't
get enough of the airport or rival porn
this repetitious cliched clips of people
giving these exasperated quotes
you know at the departing gates and
stuff they should just create stock
video every year so we don't have to go
to the airports and report on it just
use the same stuff over and over again
because like it's like we i just go to
my twitter account yeah it's just that's
all it is people people complain i enjoy
it vicariously when i'm not traveling so
i'm not going anywhere so i get to sit
there and i go and the thing is they are
there so it feels like to me that no
matter how bad it gets it never really
isn't going to stop you from going
anywhere you're still going to go
because as human beings you believe well
my flight isn't going to get canceled
their flight's going to get canceled you
know and then you show up there and
generally most of the time you're right
but this is like this is one of those
stories you do in the summertime because
you know more people are flying i
predict in this show we might do another
story on sharks
don't give it away
that's a long tease yes a judge it's
just simply
too much demand not enough supply
it's very simple but you know what i
love
pete buda judge
because this guy has tremendous
opportunity to waste your time judge
whether it's
whether it's a supply chain
or whether it's this to do something and
i wrote down the quote the guy is
talking to the airlines every day he's
watching the airlines and he wants them
to accommodate the the flyers
what the hell else are you doing i mean
really uh and that's you know during the
supply chain you know we had the worst
supply chain problem ever he was home
with the baby so uh you know and they
want to run him for president we'll have
another joe biden but the guy that i'm
impressed with is the delta ceo i love
delta i think delta's always on time i
have no stock in it don't worry about it
this guy says
i apologize he actually came out took
responsibility said i apologize and then
to get people to not fly on the
overbooked planes he said i'll give you
10 grand i want to book a flight just to
get the 10 grand to cancel it that is a
true story i did a deep dive on the 10
grand and a man a high ranking airline
like manager and operations service
manager has to
green light that but that was a puddle
jumper flight from it was from grand
rapids michigan to somewhere in
minnesota to minneapolis
and they gave people they were offering
dollars ten grand to eight different
people but jess they started doing that
in 2017 when that man was dragged off
the plane so they're afraid that they'll
have to drag somebody off the plane
involuntarily so they're giving who
doesn't take who what idiot didn't take
10 grand
if he had a girlfriend there or
something ah dump her
what dump her take the money my wife my
wife needs me with her no she doesn't
if you're going to a family event or
something i could see people you have a
wedding to get to but yes ten thousand
dollars uh should be quite inspirational
in terms of turning it over
um in today's dollars what is that
ten thousand ten still ten thousand
well i mean inflation
thank you joe biden all right
um
haven't you already answered the
question yeah
i'm just looking at the clock i'm
talking about what it's like it's time
to talk thank you
so
people to judge just in defense of when
he started he was on paternity leave and
he had a kid on a ventilator so
that's a very serious thing
okay thank you um
so the administration is kind of damned
if they do damned if they don't so
people will say well why aren't you
saying anything or why are denying
reality then he says like these things
are all going on and then he's terrible
for that too also these airlines got
billions of dollars in bailouts that's
right they need to be able to fix this i
get it the delta ceo smart to be the
first one to say that they're sorry
because now the american airlines guy is
like oh why didn't i do that and the
united guy is like why didn't i do that
so a hundred percent get out there put a
face to what's going on and say i hear
you i see you i am so sorry about this
but also just fix it you have the money
to fix it hire people back the pilot
strike i also i
i'm not a pilot trainer this 32 hours
per week when we have surgeons that are
operating on no sleep can we up that i
don't know if it's
if you're flying 32 hours a week if if
the majority of your off time is
somewhere else because you're waiting to
get back on a plane so you might be
going 60 hours a week from your home it
is you're not actually flying this isn't
a problem they can just fix because you
can't just go make more pilots right
away that's part of the problem but i
will tell you this um i live in atlanta
i fly in atlanta airport where delta's
headquartered the flights tenants and
pilots for delta are phenomenal and they
watch us they're watching right now the
management in delta has had hiccups i
think in the grand scheme of airlines i
don't know if they're any better or
worse but they kind of got stuck in this
problem because of the pandemic i mean
you have all these pilots that go under
tire early
there's all this ambiguity on are they
going to require vaccines are they not
delta did step on it when they started
basically charging an insurance premium
to those that chose not to get the
vaccine but but this is the most
important part of this segment
is that nobody makes kamala harris look
better than pete buda judge
no i mean because you talk about crisis
after crisis that she screwed up or not
been effective on i mean look at all the
transportation problems we've had and he
wasn't on paternity leave for all of it
and he never has a good answer and i'll
tell you what if the industry that can
make billions on being effective at
moving people around if they can't get
it right what's the government going to
do how are they going to fix it
they're not going to fix it well they're
going to strangle the airlines because
the airline's expected more than 50
billion dollars in a bailout so that
gives you a little bit of that's what
they're going to throw money at it's the
most impressive the most important part
of this segment is the fact that i'm
flying delta tomorrow morning and i damn
well better get off the ground well we
love delta and i said it first
one quick thing it was united that had
that incident with the pulling the man
off the plane it wasn't delta delta's
paying you 10 grand
up next democrats in the media now
warning that the planet is in jeopardy
in their latest supreme court meltdown
hi i'm brian kilmeade i want you to do
me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now